حيث افاد الجيش الاوكراني بان قواته خاضت
20 اشتباكا مع قوات روسيه على جبهات
القتال كافه في الساعات الارب عشين
الماضيه واضاف الجيش في بيان انه صد هجمات
روسيه في مارينكا وافدي فكا وشاختار في
اقليم دونباس شرقي البلاد وفي محور
زبروجيا اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تواصل تقدمها نحو مدينه
مولتوبيلا ورا
بوتين في الاثناء قتل شخص واصيب ثلاثه في
قصف روسي على اقليم خيرسون جنوب اوكرانيا
بحسب ما افادت به الاداره العسكريه في
الاقليم من جهتها نشرت مواقع عسكريه روسيه
مقاطع فيديو لقصف روسي مدفعي قالت انه
استهدف مواقع للجيش الاوكراني في محيط اف
ديفك غرب مدينه
دونتسك معنا من زبرو مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس كيف بدات اخر التطورات في
جبهات القتال
الجنوبيه نبدا من الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه
للبلاد حيث قالت الاداره العسكريه في
ميكولايف بان الوسائط القتاليه والدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه قد اعترضت طائرتين
مسيرتين من نوع اورلان 10 تابعتان للقوات
الروسيه في سماء المنطقه وهذه المسيرات هي
مسيرات تجسسيه ومسيرات تستخدم ايضا من
جانب القوات البريه الروسيه في عمليات
الحرب الالكترونيه ويبدو انها كانت في
طلعات جويه في سماء المنطقه لجمع
المعلومات وتوفيرها للقوات البريه العامله
في تلك المنطقه القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها اعترضت المسيرتين واسقطت هما في
مكان ما في اقليم في هذا في ذلك الاقليم
في ميكولايف من ناحيه اخرى ايضا اقليم
خرسون في الجنوب من البلاد هذا الاقليم
يتعرض يوميا الى عشرات الهجمات بالقذائف
المدفعيه والصاروخيه المختلفه من الجانب
الروسي هذا القصف بحسب ما افادت به
الاداره العسكريه في اقليم خرسون ادى الى
مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه اخرين على الاقل
حتى ان مدينه خرسون ذاتها تعرضت الى اكثر
من ثمانيه 28 قذيفه مدفعيه من جانب القوات
الروسيه المتمركزه على الطرف الايسر من
نهر الدنيبر من ناحيه اخرى هنا في ايضا
المحور الجنوبي لزبار جيا القصف الروسي ما
زال متواصلا على نحو 25 بلده باتت تعرف
بقرى خط المواجهه ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه هذا القصف
بحسب الاداره العسكريه هنا اسفر عن مقتل
شخص واحد على الاقل وتضرر العديد من
المنازل في هذه ال القرى نشير الى ان
القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه تقول بانها ما
زالت تحرز تقدما بطيئا على محور بفيفي
ورابوه المحور الذي يشهد حاليا ربما اكثر
المعارك ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه في تلك المنطقه التقديرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تشير الى ان القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تحرز تقدما ما بين
300 الى 400 متر يوميا في تلك المنطقه
بحسب ما افادت به بيانات الجيش الاوكراني
وهذا يدلل على بطء العمليه العسكريه هناك
وتعرض ايضا بلدات في ظهير هذه في ظهير هذا
الهجوم مثل اورخ وجولي بوليه وغيرها من
البلدات التي اصبحت تشكل الخطوط الخلفيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه المتقدمه اصبحت ايضا
عرضه للقصف المدفعي والجوي من جانب القوات
الروسيه مما يبطئ عمليه التوغل والتقدم
على محور
راوتينكس الى الوصول الى بلده توكك القائد
العسكري في تلك المنطقه الكسندر ترنسكي
قال بالامس بانه فيما اذا وقعت هذه البلده
بيد القوات الاوكرانيه وهي هو يقول بانها
اصبحت ربما ساقطه من الناحيه العسكريه
لانها اصبحت في مصب نيران المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه فان الاندفاع الاوكراني نحو
ملتبل سيكون اندفاعا سريعا وقويا من جانب
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ذلك ان ملتبل
هي المدينه التي وضعتها القوات الاوكرانيه
هدفا للوصول اليها في هذا المحور تحديدا
شكرا لك من زبروجيا مراسلنا لسكر